>> Laura: WE ARE VERY HAPPY TO
HAVE MY NEXT GUEST LIVE FOR THE
REMAINDER OF THE SHOW.
WE HAVE A LOT TO RUN THROUGH.
HIS NEW BOOK IS TITLED "LET ME
FINISH."
IT'S IN BOOKSTORES EVERYWHERE.
GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE,
THANK YOU TO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE.
CONGRATS ON THE NEW BOOK.
YOU'VE BEEN ON EVERY SHOW EXCEPT
LIKE FARM TOOLS WEEKLY.
>> [LAUGHS]
>> Laura: WHAT IS THIS?
WHAT ARE WE HERE QUESTION MIKE
THAT'S ALL RIGHT, I HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS.
IS >> I CAN'T BELIEVE I'M NOT ON
FARM TOOLS WEEKLY.
>> Laura: GET THE P.R. PERSON
ON IT.
ALL RIGHT, I WANT IS SOMETHING
YOU SAID ON COLBERT LAST NIGHT.
IF YOU DON'T COME ON MY SHOW
FIRST, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
REALLY BE MEAN TO YOU.
JUST TEASING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> DO YOU REGRET --
>> I MADE A DECISION AT THE TIME
I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO WIN
THE NOMINATION AFTER I DROPPED
OUT OF THE NIGHT I PREFERRED HIM
TO HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT'S WHY I MADE THE DECISION.
IT WASN'T A WHOLE LOT MORE
COMPLICATED THAN THAT.
I STILL AGREE WITH WHAT HIS
POLICIES ARE MORE THAN I AGREE
WITH HILLARY CLINTON.
HE HAS TURNED THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY INTO SOMETHING DIFFERENT
THAN WHEN I STARTED TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
>> Laura: WOULD YOU CONSIDER
THAT SOMETHING DIFFERENT GOOD
OR BAD, ULTIMATELY FOR THE
G.O.P., GOVERNOR?
>> IN SOME WAYS GOOD AND IN SOME
WAYS BAD, FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
IN THE GOOD WAYS HE'S TURNED IT,
I THINK HIS TOUGHNESS ON CHINA
HAS BEEN SOMETHING THAT THE
PARTY NEEDED FOR QUITE SOME
TIME, AND I THINK HIS CONTINUED
EFFORTS IN THAT REGARD.
HIS CONTINUED EFFORTS AND TRADE
IN GENERAL I THINK ARE GOOD AND
HE'S GOTTEN MUCH BETTER BETTER
DEAL WITH CANADA AND MEXICO THAN
WE HAD BEFORE.
I THINK THOSE SAME THINGS WITH
THE EEO.
AND WITH JAPAN.
I THINK HE'S BEEN BETTER FOR US
IN TERMS OF OUR REGULATORY
POLICIES AND IS PUT MORE FOCUS
THAN WE WERE PUTTING ON ONE WE
CONTROL CONGRESS AND COULD HAVE
DONE MORE THERE TOO.
ON REGULATORY ISSUES.
IN THE PLACES WHERE I DISAGREE,
I THINK THEIR TIMES, IN FOREIGN
POLICY WHERE HE ASKED
IMPULSIVELY.
WHETHER IT'S DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
SYRIA AND THE CROSSCURRENTS
INVOLVED THERE.
I THINK YOU SHOULD TAKE A MORE
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH.
I THINK HE IS NOW TAKING A MORE
DELIBERATIVE APPROACH.
LISTEN, IN THE MAIN, I WOULD SAY
HE'S MADE A PARTY BETTER BECAUSE
HE WON.
HE BEAT HILLARY CLINTON.
>> Laura: DO YOU THINK, YOU
KNOW, I'VE BEEN A BIG FAN OF
YOURS FOR A LONG TIME.
EVERYONE WHO'S LISTEN TO MY
INTERVIEWS WITH YOU ON THE RADIO
KNOW THAT.
DO YOU THINK YOU COULD HAVE
BEATEN HILLARY CLINTON IN OHIO,
PENNSYLVANIA, WISCONSIN,
ALTHOUGH STATES?
>> YES.
>> Laura: YOU DO?
>> I ABSOLUTELY DO.
>> Laura: BECAUSE OF YOUR
POSITIONS ON TRADE, IMMIGRATION?
THE THINGS THAT MOTIVATED THOSE
VOTERS TO TURN OUT.
OBVIOUSLY HAD THE MONEY RAISED.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT I
THINK HILLARY CLINTON WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY FLAWED CANDIDATE
AND SHE NEEDED SOMEONE WHO WAS
GOING TO BE DIRECT AND GO AT
HER.
AND CALL HER OUT ON ALL THE
THINGS THAT SHE HAD DONE AS
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
THINGS SHE WAS PROPOSING AND HOW
PREPOSTEROUS THEY WERE.
THE WAY WE WOULD LOSE CLINTON IS
IF WE HAD A CANDIDATE WHO WAS
NOT DIRECT, WHO IS NOT BLUNT,
WHO WAS PART OF THE OLD GUARD,
WHETHER THAT WAS JEB BUSH OR
MARCO RUBIO OR SCOTT WALKER.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THOSE GUYS
WOULD'VE BEEN ABLE TO PULL IT
OFF BECAUSE THEY WOULD'VE BEEN
MORE PC.
>> Laura: THEY WEREN'T
ENTOMBED TO THE PARTY.
I'M GETTING YOU CAUGHT IN A
PROSECUTORIAL TRAP AND YOU DON'T
EVEN KNOW IT.
THAT'S WHY I LOVE HAVING YOU ON.
[LAUGHS]
SO LOOK, I ASKED YOU WHETHER THE
PARTY WENT INTO A GOOD OR BAD
DIRECTION AND YOU SAID THE OLD
GUARD WOULDN'T HAVE BEATEN
HILLARY.
YOU ARE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
THEY COULDN'T WIN THEIR HOME
STATE, GOVERNOR.
THEY COULDN'T WIN FLORIDA.
THEY COULDN'T WIN THEIR KEY
STATES.
MITT ROMNEY COULDN'T WIN
MICHIGAN.
THEY COULDN'T WIN.
THE NEW GUY COMES IN AND SAYS I
THINK ALL YOUR POLICIES HAVE
BEEN WRONG ON TRADE.
HE THINKS THAT FOREIGN POLICY
HAD BEEN TOO INTERVENTIONIST IN
IRAQ AND OTHER PARTS OF THE
MIDDLE EAST.
WE HAVE UPSET THE APPLE CART
THERE.
I THINK THE PEOPLE, THAT REALLY
GOT THEIR ATTENTION BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE VERY WAR-WEARY,
WHETHER IT'S SYRIA.
THEY ARE VERY WAR-WHERE HE
APPEARED WE HAVE 2,000 TROOPS IN
SYRIA.
EVERYONE WANTS TO KNOCK THE CRAP
OUT OF ISIS AND TRUMP'S LEG
WHERE ARE OUR GUYS STILL GETTING
KILLED THERE?
THE PARTIES TURNED WAS IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION UNDER TRUMP, AND
I THINK YOU WERE CLOSER TO THAT
THAN THOSE OTHER GUYS.
>> IN THE MAIN, I SAY IT WAS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THE BIGGEST
THING HE DID WAS WIN.
THOSE AREAS IN FOREIGN POLICY
WHERE I'VE DISAGREED WITH HIM AT
TIMES AND I MAY BE EVERMORE
AGGRESSIVE, INTERVENTIONIST
POLICY THAN HE HAD, I DON'T
THINK THAT WOULD'VE DETERMINED
THE LAWS OF THE ELECTION TO ME
WHEN CONTRASTED TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
IN THE END, DOESN'T MATTER.
HE WAS THE NOMINEE.
I WAS THE FIRST PERSON TO GO OUT
AND SUPPORT HIM.
YOU WERE TELLING ME I SHOULD DO
THAT.
AND I WENT OUT AND I DID IT.
I THINK, YOU KNOW, THAT
REPRESENTED A BIG MOMENT IN THE
CAMPAIGN, SOMEONE WHO HAD BEEN
SEEN AS PART OF THE MAINSTREAM
BECAUSE I WAS A GOVERNOR, EVEN
THOUGH A VERY DIFFERENT KIND OF
GOVERNOR IN A BLUE STATE, YOU
KNOW, I THINK THAT WAS A BIG
TURNING POINT IN THE PRIMARY
CAMPAIGN WHICH I BELIEVED HE WAS
GOING TO WIN.
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT, FOR THE
GENERAL ELECTION.
>> Laura: WE ARE GOING TO GET
INTO MORE OF WHAT MIGHT BE IN
YOUR FUTURE DOWN THE ROAD.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FROM
HIM TODAY OR YESTERDAY MAY BE.
THIS IS CHUCK SCHUMER TALKING
ABOUT THESE BORDER NEGOTIATIONS
THAT ARE ONGOING, PERHAPS TO
AVERT ANOTHER GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWN.
LET'S WATCH.
>> WE HAVE COME TO BIG
AGREEMENTS BEFORE ON BUDGETS AND
RUSSIAN SANCTIONS.
WHAT WAS THE COMMON THEME?
WHEN THE PRESIDENT STAYS OUT OF
THE NEGOTIATIONS, WE ALMOST
ALWAYS SUCCEED.
WHEN HE MIXES IN, IT'S A FORMULA
FOR FAILURE.
I WOULD ASK PRESIDENT TRUMP, LET
CONGRESS DEAL WITH IT ON ITS
OWN.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT SCHUMER,
YOUR OLD NEMESIS?
>> THE REASON HE DOESN'T WANT
DONALD TRUMP INVOLVED IS BECAUSE
HE WANTS TO TRY TO ROLLOVER
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS.
I JUST THINK THE IDEA, YOU KNOW,
I USED TO HAVE A SAYING IN
TRENTON THAT THERE WERE ONLY
THREE IMPORTANT NUMBERS IN
TRENTON.
41, 21, 1.
41 VOTES IN THE LOWER HOUSE, 21
IN THE UPPER HOUSE, AND ONE
WHICH WAS THE SIGNATURE OF THE
GOVERNOR.
IT'S THE SAME THING WITH
DIFFERENT NUMBERS IN THE
CONGRESS.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE PRESIDENT
INVOLVES, YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
COME TO A SOLUTION.
SO THE IDEA THAT HE WANTS TO
KEEP THE PRESIDENT OUT I THINK
IT'S VERY MACHIAVELLIAN IN HIS
PART.
HE DOESN'T WANT THE TOUGHEST GUY
IN THE ROOM AT THE TABLE.
HE WANTS TO ROLL SOME PEOPLE.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS TO BE
INVOLVED.
ANY NEGOTIATION WITHOUT THE
PRESIDENT IS DOOMED FOR FAILURE
BECAUSE HE WON'T AGREE.
>> Laura: I THOUGHT IT WAS
LUDICROUS.
WHEN SOMEONE HAS THEIR GLASSES
DOWN ON THEIR
>> Laura: BACK WITH ME NOW IS
CHRIS CHRISTIE.
I WANT TO START WITH YOUR
APPEARANCE ON COLBERT AGAIN LAST
NIGHT AND AN INTERESTING COMMENT
YOU MADE ON YOUR BOOK TOUR.
LET'S WATCH.
>> JOINED ME ON THIS ONE.
GOOD QUESTION.
HERE WE GO.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> WOULD YOU HAVE BEEN A BETTER
PRESIDENT THAN TRUMP?
>> YES.
>> I LIKE THAT.
>> Laura: OKAY.
SO A LOT OF MODESTY, A LOT OF
TEQUILA.
I LIKE IT.
OBVIOUSLY, LAST NIGHT ON
COLBERT.
WHAT DOES TRUMP NEED TO DO TO
WIN IN 2020?
ARE THE DEMOCRATS, WE STARTED
THE SHOW BY TALKING ABOUT THE
LURCH TO THE LEFT OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
INFANTICIDE, GREEN ENERGY.
ARE THE LEFT HELPING TRUMP NOW
AS WE MOVE INTO THE ELECTION
CYCLE?
>> THEY ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
HELPING HIM BY CONTINUING TO
MOVE TO THE LEFT, PUTTING PEOPLE
LIKE ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ
OUT IN FRONT, BEING A
SPOKESWOMAN FOR THE PARTY,
TALKING ABOUT A 70% TAX RATE,
KAMALA HARRIS TALKING ABOUT
ELIMINATING HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND HAVING INSURANCE
FOR ALL.
LET'S NOT FORGET OUR FRIEND
HOWARD SCHULTZ, I'M GOING TO GET
A T-SHIRT MADE UP THAT SAYS RUN,
HOWARD, RUN."
GET IN THERE, RUN AS AN
INDEPENDENT.
ALL THOSE THINGS ARE PROCESS
THINGS THAT ARE HELPING TO SHAPE
THE LANDSCAPE TO MAKE THE
CONTRAST EVEN BETTER.
WHAT YOU WANT IN AN ELECTION
POLITICALLY IS A GREAT CONTRAST.
YOU HAD A GREAT CONTRAST BETWEEN
DONALD TRUMP AND
HILLARY CLINTON.
THAT'S WHAT WE WANT AGAIN.
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO MUDDLE
THINGS UP IN THE MIDDLE.
WE WANT CONTRAST.
DO YOU WANT A SOCIALIST SOCIETY
OR DO YOU WANT A CAPITALISTIC
SOCIETY?
DO YOU WANT A SOCIETY THAT
RESPECTS LIFE OR DO YOU WANT A
SOCIETY THAT DENIGRATES ALIVE?
DO YOU WANT A SOCIETY THAT GIVES
OPPORTUNITY FOR EVERYBODY, OR
WERE GOVERNMENT CONTROLS
EVERYTHING?
DONALD TRUMP HAS TO BE ABLE TO
DRAW THAT PICTURE VERY STARKLY
AND CLEARLY.
THE DEMOCRATS, DOING WHAT THEY
ARE DOING, ARE GOING TO HELP
THEM.
HE NEEDS TO GET BETTER PEOPLE
AROUND HIM.
SO MANY OF THE MISTAKES IN THE
FIRST TWO YEARS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION, AND I WRITE
ABOUT THIS IN THE BOOK, HAVE
BEEN UNFORCED ERRORS.
UNNECESSARY ERRORS BY PEOPLE WHO
DON'T HAVE THE EXPERIENCE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT'S GREAT TO BE A DISRUPTER.
I WAS A DISRUPTER IN TRENTON.
I WAS A DISRUPTER IN WASHINGTON.
BUT I ALSO NEED TO HAVE PEOPLE
AROUND ME AND HE NEEDS TO PEOPLE
AROUND HIM.
ME AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR, HIM
AS A BUSINESSMAN, THAT
UNDERSTANDS THE POLITICS OF THE
CAPITAL.
IT HELPS TO AVOID SOME OF THIS
UNFORCED ERRORS LIKE GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWNS.
>> Laura: CHRIS.
I THINK I SHOULD CALL YOU
GOVERNOR, EVEN THOUGH YOU'RE MY
FRIEND.
GOVERNOR, I THINK YOU ARE MAKING
THE CASE FOR YOU TO BE THE CHIEF
OF STAFF.
EVERYBODY KNOWS I PUSHED FOR YOU
TO BE CHIEF OF STAFF.
I TALKED ABOUT IT ON RADIO,
TRULY DID ABOUT IT.
I'M NOT GETTING INTO KUSHNER.
I THINK IT'S POINTLESS TO TALK
ABOUT AND EVERYONE HAS HEADED TO
DEATH AND IT'S BORING FOR MY
VIEWERS.
MY VIEWERS WANT TO KNOW, CHRIS
CHRISTIE IS NO NONSENSE.
YOU'VE KNOWN TRUMP FOR ALL THESE
YEARS.
YOU HAVE A GOOD MANAGERIAL
SENSE.
YOU ARE NO-NONSENSE, AND YOU CAN
TAKE CRITICISM.
I'VE SEEN YOU TAKE CRITICISM
BECAUSE I'VE GIVEN IT TO YOU AND
YOU ACTUALLY LISTEN TO PEOPLE.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER GOING INTO
THE WHITE HOUSE AS A CHIEF OF
STAFF OR EVEN MANAGING THE 2020
REELECTION CAMPAIGN FOR THIS
PRESIDENT?
I HAVE ALWAYS TOLD THE PRESIDENT
THAT WHEN HE CALLS, I WILL
ANSWER THE PHONE AND I WILL
LISTEN TO WHAT HE HAS TO OFFER.
I ALWAYS HAVE AND I ALWAYS WILL.
FOR TWO REASONS.
ONE BECAUSE I LOVE MY COUNTRY.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A COUNTRY
GOVERNED BY THE LIBERAL
DEMOCRATS OUT THERE RUNNING.
AND TWO COME HE'S MY FRIEND AND
I'M LOYAL TO MY FRIENDS.
>> Laura: EVA COUNTED THAT YOU
DON'T FEEL LIKE HE WAS LOYAL TO
YOU.
>> HE WASN'T.
>> Laura: THAT'S IN THE BOOK.
I'VE READ IT ALL.
IT'S A LESSON IN HUMILITY.
YOU ARE A BIG PERSONALITY BUT
YOU HAD TO HUMBLE YOURSELF.
WE ALL HAVE GONE THROUGH THOSE
MOMENTS.
THAT'S IN THE BOOK.
>> THE BOOK TALKS ABOUT THE UPS
AND DOWNS OF MY LIFE.
WHEN YOU GET KNOCKED DOWN IT'S
ABOUT GETTING UP AND FIGHTING
FOR THE THINGS THAT YOU BELIEVE
AND IN YOUR HEART, LITERATURE
FAMILY, WHETHER IT'S BECAUSE YOU
BELIEVE IN, PHILANTHROPIC CAUSE
OR WHETHER IT'S YOUR COUNTRY.
WHILE THOSE THINGS ARE THINGS
WORTH FIGHTING FOR AND IT'S
NEVER A STRAIGHT LINE UP, LAURA.
IT HASN'T BEEN FOR ME.
NOT FOR YOU.
YOU KNOW FOR US, WE ARE
FIGHTERS.
I'M GOING TO FIGHT, AND IF THE
PRESIDENT ASKED ME TO FIGHT FOR
HIM, I WILL ALWAYS LISTEN TO A
REQUEST TO FIGHT FOR MY
PRESIDENT ON MY COUNTRY.
>> Laura: TO THE BOOK GET IN
THE WAY OF YOU BECOMING CHIEF OF
STAFF?
THAT WOULD'VE BEEN KIND OF
AWKWARD IF THE BOOK WERE COMING
OUT.
>> KNOW BECAUSE IF I HAD
ACCEPTED CHIEF OF STAFF AT THAT
TIME, THE BOOK WOULD NOT HAVE
COME OUT AND THAT WAS PART OF
THE DEAL.
>> Laura: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
A REPORT IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AT THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL WAS CUTTING
SOME SECRET DEAL WITH THE
DEMOCRATS THAT WOULD'VE ENSURE
THEY WOULD'VE GOTTEN A LIBERAL
PICK AS A COMPROMISE ON THE
NINTH CIRCUIT.
WE LEARNED TODAY, AND I LEARNED
TODAY THAT THIS WAS ALL
COMPLETE, YOU KNOW BOWL, YOU
KNOW WHAT.
TONIGHT IT WAS CONFIRMED THAT
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED HIS
INTENTION TO NOMINATE THE STARS
IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT.
DANIEL COLLINS, DANIEL BRESS,
AND KENNETH LEE.
TWO OF THEM WERE SCALIA CLERKS.
THEY ARE PHENOMENAL.
WHY IS IT SO IMPORTANT -- THE
PRESIDENT HAS DONE WELL ON
JUDGES.
WHY IS IT SO IMPORTANT TO THIS
NINTH CIRCUIT IS NOT ALLOWED TO
BECOME A RUNAWAY, YOU KNOW,
INJUNCTION TRAIN THAT'S GOING TO
RUN OVER THE PRESIDENT'S
POLICIES.
>> THAT'S WHAT IT IS RIGHT NOW,
LAURA.
IT IS A RUNAWAY INJUNCTION
TRAIN.
EVERYBODY RUNS TO THE
NINTH CIRCUIT AND LOWER DISTRICT
COURTS IN THE NINTH CIRCUIT TO
CHALLENGE THE PRESIDENT'S
ACTIONS, BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT
THE NINTH CIRCUIT IS THE MOST
ACTIVIST, ULTRALIBERAL OF ALL
OUR CIRCUITS.
THAT'S WHY THESE NOMINATIONS ARE
SO IMPORTANT.
DONALD TRUMP PROMISED TO
TRANSFORM THE FEDERAL COURTS,
AND HE'S DONE GREAT WORK, GREAT
WORK AT THE SUPREME COURT AND
THE CIRCUIT COURTS.
HE HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO GET --
CRACKED THE CODE AND THE
NINTH CIRCUIT.
HE GOES IN WITH LINDSEY GRAHAM,
PUSHES THESE NOMINATIONS FROM
FIGHTS, IT'S GOING TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, CONGRATS
ON THE BOOK.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR